Hello, I'm Brett Lider, the
Design Lead for Android Wear
and welcome to the Android Wear
2.0 Developer Preview Tour.
Let's talk about
Android Wear 2.0.
So, as always, Android
Wear starts you out
on the watch face.
Here I've got a watch
face that's very 1.0.
It's beautiful,
but it doesn't have
a lot of information and action
on it to help me with my day.
So I'm going to swipe from left
to right on the watch face.
And what that does is
zooms out on the watch face
and actually helps me
select my next watch
face, Elements Analog.
Elements Analog is
a watch face that we
built to demonstrate
the capabilities
of the complication's API.
I've already customized it with
a set of things that help me.
So let's dig into this.
Maybe I want to change
one of these complications
from calories to tracking how
much water I've had to drink.
So I just swipe left or
right to zoom out a bit.
I tap on the gear icon.
I tap on the Complications,
the left one,
and we've worked with Lifesum,
a third party partner,
to have them be a data
provider for these two things.
So I'm going to switch over
to water as the complication.
And, boom, I've just
changed from calories
to tracking how many
glasses of water,
and it looks like I'm a little
behind on my water today.
But I can just as easily
launch Strava, check out
what's going on in
my calendar, or see
what time it is in London.
And each of these
complications is interactive,
in that I can tap
to get more details
and launch into that app.
Let's keep going.
Let's go over to this next
watch face, Ranger by Zuhanden.
And here, Ranger, which has a
completely different aesthetic,
but its styling,
its complications
to match that aesthetic, yet
it's using the data providers.
So it's got the time zone in
Boston, where my family lives.
It's also got the
water tracker, and it's
got the day of the month.
So we really think
that watch faces
should own the presentation
of their complications
to make those complications
fit in so nicely with the watch
face.
So I've got Ranger here.
Let's see what else I might be
interested in for a watch face.
So at the end of the
watch face Favorites,
I've got a list of all
the watch faces that
are available on the device.
And I'll pick
Elements Digital here,
and now I've added that to my
Favorites, so I've got four.
Mm, I don't need this
1.0-style watch face anymore.
So I'm going to get rid of it.
So all I have to do is just
swipe it up, and it's gone.
And now Elements Analog
is my watch face.
So now that we've shown how to
select and discard watch faces,
let's go check out another core
capability of Android Wear,
which is how you get back.
So here I might be deep in my
list of possible watch faces,
and I decide none of these
quite resonate with me,
so I want to go back.
So I'll I have to do is hit
the Hardware button here once
to go back to the
list of Favorites,
and then once more to go back
to my default watch face.
So hitting the Hardware button
on the side of the device
is just how you get back,
and it's super fast.
So up next, let's take a look at
what we call the Quick Settings
shade.
So I'll have to do is pull down
from the top edge of the watch
face, and I've got
all the controls
that I might need to
access in a hurry,
especially I want to
focus on brightness.
So we've heard from
users that brightness
needed to be easier to access.
And so here, that's
what we've done.
So all you have to do
is tap up and down,
and you get a live preview
of the brightness right
on top of your watch face.
So now I'll hit the Back button
on the side of the watch once
and then a second time, and
I'm back on the watch face.
Now that we've seen watch
faces and Quick Settings.
Let's check out apps.
So once I'm on the watch face
and the screen is fully on,
all I have to do is
hit the Hardware button
on the side of the
watch and, boom,
that launches the App Launcher.
Let's try that again.
So I'm on the watch face, and
I just hit the Hardware button
on the side.
and I'm into the App Launcher.
And so the App Launcher,
as you can tell,
has this round-specific
layout for round watches,
and it's also going the
scroll bar on the side.
So I can really quickly
and easily maybe even
fling down to the
app that I want.
And once when I've found
that app, like Strava,
I get zoomed into it.
And so I can interact with
Strava here, go on a bike ride.
And then when I'm done, I
hit the Hardware button,
and I go back out
to the App Launcher,
right where I was before.
And if I leave the App Launcher,
hit the Hardware button
to go back to the watch
face, and, of course,
if I had the Hardware again to
go back into the App Launcher,
here's Strava right at the
top of the App Launcher.
So the apps that I use
the most are really
easy to get to in
the App Launcher.
So let's go back out
to the watch face.
And now let's check
out messaging.
So messaging is something we've
spent a lot of time focusing on
with Android Wear 2.0 to
make a really, really good.
So if my watch was
in Always On mode
and I received a
notification from a friend,
that notification comes
up over my watch face
Always On mode and
shows for a few seconds
before it goes away,
Then, when I wake
my watch back up,
that notification will come
and visit my watch face
for a few seconds
and then go away.
So it doesn't cover
up my watch face,
but I can see that I
got a notification.
So when I'm ready,
I can scroll up
and start interacting
with that notification.
So here Krystal's
sent me a notification
during my demo-- awesome.
So, yeah, I'll reply
to Krystal here,
and I think I'll end up using
the keyboard because I want
to be pretty expressive
and specific,
but I'm already talking, so I
can't really speak my reply.
So I'm using my
suggestions here,
which I would say are
indeed pretty good.
And the demo seems to be going
pretty good so far as well.
So I just approve
that and reply,
and I can see that
my message has
been appended to
our conversation,
and my conversation's
been persisted.
And Krystal's already
replied-- awesome.
Well, I'm done with this
conversation with Krystal
for now, so I'll
hit the Back button,
and I'll be taken
back to the stream.
And I can scroll
down, and I see I've
got a message from Alexandra,
and I've got some activity
from Google Fit.
And, as you can see,
as I'm scrolling,
I can see a scroll
bar in thumbnail
that lets me know exactly
where I am in the stream
and approximately how
many notifications I
have to deal with.
So I'll hit the Hardware
button, go back up
to the top at my watch face,
and that concludes our tour.
Thanks, everyone.
Let us know what you
think about the developer
preview of Android Wear 2.0.